might europe be on the cusp of a new era
of nuclear power
beginning today the controversial energy
source is getting more support on the eu
level as the czech republic assumes the
eu council presidency
leaders there say pushing up support for
atomic energy is a priority
parts of europe germany denmark and
austria in particular have fiercely
opposed efforts to encourage nuclear in
the past
prague however sees things differently
a special delivery from russia as the
war rages in ukraine
uranium fuel rods are being delivered to
the thamily nuclear power plant in the
czech republic
many lights would go out in the country
without the russian uranium fuel rods
nuclear power accounts for 40 percent of
the country's energy production
the delivered fuel rods will keep the
nuclear reactors running for the next
few years
i'm for nuclear energy
it's one of the few energy sources where
everything works
i'm a geologist i know about it and i
have a clear opinion we should have
built more nuclear power plants long ago
then we would have safe energy today
the czech republic's two nuclear power
plants at tamalin and ducavani are aging
both were built during the soviet era
the reactor in ducavani is a mix of
western control technology and soviet
engineering the nuclear power plant has
never reached western safety standards
there were repeated emergency shutdowns
caused by defective components
meanwhile the expansion of renewable
energies has been prevented and delayed
the geographical location of our country
is not good for wind energy for example
we don't have a sea where the wind blows
strongly
and we don't have much sun especially in
winter
that's why nuclear energy is so
important in our energy mix
the czech republic has never had a
significant anti-nuclear movement one of
the country's few well-known opponents
is karel polanski he's critical of the
government's plans to build two new
nuclear power plants by 2036.
it's perceived as a major capacity of
the country to master a complicated
technology like nuclear power
many people are proud of the fact that
the czech republic can organize the
construction of a nuclear power plant
it's seen as something positive
the latest uranium fuel rods from russia
will keep the czech nuclear reactors
online for another three to four years
after that they will be replaced by
western made ones which will have to be
technically adapted
karen pittle heads the efo center for
energy climate and resources in munich
she joins me for more
karen i want to start with germany we
just heard about the czech republic
there
germany is phasing out nuclear energy at
the same time it's facing an energy
crunch in the short term because of
russia and in the long term because of
climate is it just a matter of time
before berlin begins to take nuclear
seriously again
um i don't believe though
uh i believe so at least not in the long
run um there is at the moment
discussions about
prolonging the duration at which the
remaining three it's only three um power
plants could be running so either
kind of like letting them run longer
with the existing or the already the few
rods already in place or
have one more round if you want of new
fuel rods but in the long term i don't
see a future of nuclear energy in
germany what's the biggest opposition
from germany briefly if you can there's
a long history of course behind this but
how would you explain this to viewers
who might not be familiar with it
i mean it's a couple of issues but i
think safety is one of the main concerns
and also the question what do you do
with the fuel rods once they are taken
out of the reactor and have to be stored
somewhere permanently so both aspects
are really
behind the
discussion about nuclear energy and now
combined also with the fact that
renewable energies have become so much
cheaper in the last decades we know the
czech republic and france are among
those countries planning build outs
belgium and korea have reversed their
plans to phase out nuclear um is nuclear
a long-term solution for these countries
or is it just a bridging to get to
perhaps a wider build out of renewables
what are we seeing
and for some countries it's actually
something that they want to pursue in
the long run the czech republic for
example
they are opposing the stipulations in
the taxonomy in the eu taxonomy so far
that it is only to be considered as
bridging technology they really want to
use nuclear power to actually
decarbonize their power system in the
long run
you mentioned the eu taxonomy that of
course uh sort of ranks or i would say
provides a pathway for investors to um
invest in energy sources that are
considered green or that in accordance
with a climate transition nuclear has
controversially been put on there that
that's sort of wobbling right now
in your opinion does it help nuclear uh
for it to be on that list is that
something that should happen
in my opinion it does help nuclear
because if you're on that list you're
more easily
get access to state funding public
funding public support
um for building new plans so that
definitely helps
the question whether it should be on
there is a different one i do not
believe the soul because it's not a
green technology it might be climate
neutral technology or at least with
loans
but to consider it green and with low
environmental hazards i find that really
problematic but the same holds of course
also with respect to nuclear gas which
is a natural gas which is also on that
list
the iea the international energy agency
released a report
today saying that nuclear needs to play
or should be considered as a major a
part of climate transitions for many
countries and without nuclear it will be
much more difficult is germany putting
itself in a bind by not going to nuclear
as it tries to transition to
climate-friendly energy sources and stay
away from russian energy
i do not believe at this point anymore
if we had decided earlier to stay in
nuclear power it might make a difference
but starting to build new nuclear power
plants now as i said we only have three
remaining that are running uh would take
very long so it would take 10 to 15
years to buy build the new ones and also
nuclear power is by no means cheap when
you buy
build new nuclear power plants so for
germany as an option to decrease their
emissions from our emissions from um
power production fast it is not really
an option
all right karen piddles director of the
efo center for energy climate and
resources thank you very much